kouchner bonsoir je voudrais d'abord
vous poser quelques questions simples
je m'adresse non pas à l'homme politique
nos médecins est ce que ce soit vous
pourriez être vous cet homme ce médecin
qui a été relaxé est ce que pour y être
à sa place
oui oui en effet il m'est arrivé d'être
confrontés à des situations comme
celle-là pour moi la décision fut plus
collective peut-être merci de cette
franchise
une autre question tout aussi direct nul
ne sait s'il y aura des poursuites
pénales
mais qu'adviendra-t-il à ce médecin
apparemment l'hôpital attend une réponse
du ministère est ce qu'il va être
réintégré dans son service est ce qu'il
va être muté
ce qui va être envoyée nous fournirons
cette réponse je crois légitime de
peut-être lui permettre de travailler
dans un autre contexte mais en même
temps de ne pas le sanctionner
c'est très clair entre question là aussi
tout aussi claire on ne sait pas si le
conseil de l'ordre va faire appel de la
décision de ce conseil de l'ordre
régionales mais que dites vous aux
professeurs glorian qui dirige le
conseil de l'ordre que lui dit vous et
que répondez-vous lorsqu'il vous
reproche d'avoir parlé d'un acte de
s'arrêter je lui reproche de faire
semblant de ne pas comprendre
j'ai beaucoup d'affection pour lui je
pense que il est responsable de la
déontologie je comprends très bien est
ce qu'il a lu tout à l'heure bien sûr
nous sommes les médecins en charge de la
vie pas de la mort met les choses au
change et l'évolution des temps les
équipes la fin de vie ce très beau mot
d'accompagnement je crois qu'il faut
débattre de tout cela je souhaite
personnellement mais je n'ai aucun
conseil à donner à bernard blot riant
qu'il n'y ait pas d'appel mais qu on
puisse débattre
c'est un débat très difficile mais
toutes les opinions
je les ai entendues elles sont
respectables parlons-en
il s'agit toujours de soi même de ses
parents de son amour justement est ce qu
a pas une énorme hypocrisie des
instances politiques morales religieuses
médical qui laisse au fond dans un
désarroi énorme lieu personnel soignant
qui lui est confrontée au quotidien et
les familles
drame de la vie on nous répète depuis
des années qu'il faut débattre et depuis
des années on observe les mêmes drames
oui vous avez raison il ya beaucoup
d'hypocrisie trop d'hypocrisie
mais d'abord le débat aura lieu il
commence dans les états généraux
maintenant dans les jours qui viennent
je souhaite qu'il y ait de plus de débat
possible autour non pas de l'euthanasie
oublions ce mot horrible mais de la fin
de vie de l'accompagnement de l'équipe
de la tendresse de la manière dont
ensemble nous pouvons prendre en charge
nos amis nos parents nos frères
deuxièmement la loi
c'est pas simple et vous savez
personnellement je crois qu'il ne faut
pas légiférer ou alors peut-être se
pencher sur le cas des poursuites pour
les uns ou pour les autres mais
légiférer c'est quoi ces froidement
déterminer à quel moment on va agir non
c'est pas ça je ne crois pas il y aura
encore sans hypocrisie quelques cas de
ce genre mais si les soins palliatifs
comme je le souhaite
sont distribués à travers le pays ce qui
est loin d'être le cas que de promesses
ça fait combien d'années qu'on répète en
effet qu'il faut lutter contre la
douleur qu'il faut multiplier les soins
palliatifs qu'il faut des équipes
mobiles vous le dites d'autres l'ont dit
avant vous voyez comme les choses à plat
mais vous avez raison
oui moi je crois et je ne crache pas je
ne sais pas ce qui s'est passé avant je
sais ce qui s'est passé avant il ya eu
des progrès en france il y aura de
l'argent je serai peut-être demain ou
après demain combien pour les soins
palliatifs la douleur est prise en
charge pour la première fois il n'y aura
plus de carnet à souches pour la
première fois ses infirmières dont vous
avez raison de parler et qui sont
souvent les plus isolés à prendre des
responsabilités et à contempler la
souffrance pourront elles mêmes en tout
cas comme et au maximum la souffrance
sans qu'on cherche le médecin à
l'intérieur de l'hôpital
il y à une formation qui doit être fait
on n'apprend pas à comment dirais-je
supprimer la souffrance au contraire
dans notre école de clinique
on l'entendait on l'attendait comme un
signe tout ça va disparaître
il faut du temps oui j'espère en tout
cas c'est ma volonté très forte celle du
gouvernement ont pris acte ce serait
peut-être vous pourrez revenir dans
quelques mois pour faire une premier
bilan six pieds aussi à dallas parce que
nous ferons rien son opinion mais blé on
y participent sont croisés la géniale où
l'amour ça font énormément leur travail
d'urgence blessure mais de débattre
ensemble nous débattons de ce sujet
alors cela devient
un sujet majeur et nous pourrons prendre
des décisions plus facilement tout autre